how do you think nick fury would react
to this type of reception um
you know comic con is is phenomenal it's
it's totally amazing it's like every
year i've been coming here since like
episode one star wars um
so
seems like every year i come here and it
validates
the fact that i belong and i i get all
this energy and love from everybody that
makes me feel like going out and making
movies for the rest of the year
[Applause]
we make we we make movies because we
want to entertain you guys and i make
movies because i want to see myself in
them and
this is the perfect combination for me
all this love and
it just energizes me and i can't wait to
come back next year with the next movie
excellent congratulations on the success
of winter soldier yes
yes
do you feel like
do you feel like at this point that
steve that cap is like fit does he feel
more acclimated to this world yet or
does he still feel a little isolated
well no i think he's getting there i
think we're past you know he's not just
you know amazed at cell phones and the
internet i mean i think he's he's up to
speed but i think he's still looking for
a place to belong you know he's he's for
so long been
a servant you know he fits in
as a soldier you know he's used to kind
of this uh chain of command and since
shields kind of fell apart in the last
movie it's it's more about
this group of people depending upon each
other without kind of a clear leader and
i think he's searching for you know home
how has it felt coming into this
established world with all these people
who've been working together as as kind
of as the new guy
yeah you know
pretty overwhelming um
and and surreal and uh you know i was
flattered to you know that joss and the
marvel guys approached me for this and
you know
don't hesitate you know it's uh
huge you know it's incredible to be a
part of this gang and
great actors and uh you know
you know was there anything about doing
a superhero film that you never
envisioned before like what what's
different about it than other stuff that
you've done
what the avengers yeah
i think you know i mean you know it's
just the
the characters you have such a dynamic
between you know the group and i think
you know what josh did with the first
one was
uh
it seemed like a
a mission completely impossible to do um
but everyone had their moment and stood
out and you know what's beautiful is you
get these kind of characters in the same
room and they bounce off of each other
you know there's banter and humor and
it's uh
and uh and he has that tone where it can
be have a journey and and be emotional
and sad at moments and and uh and you
know light-hearted and action-packed you
know
it's you know i i i thoroughly enjoy all
the marvel movies and and was so excited
to be a part of this one and how's that
experience been for you
everybody's been incredibly
welcoming and it's been you know it's
the most ex
it's exciting for me it's been the most
exciting thing that's ever happened to
my children
do you get cool dad points for this i
simply
had no interest in what i did until this
month
so that's been cool is this your first
comic con
i came last year to comic con for a tv
show i do called the blacklist
[Applause]
and you know i i just want to say
something to all of you guys is
i have
i've always thought my whole life that
life could never get weird or crazy
enough for me
and
i got to tell you something
this place may be the weirdest craziest
place i've ever been
congratulations it's because of all of
you guys and so i thank you for that
because it is really
fantastically crazy here
just nuts doing this film was
everything
everything was so entirely new
uh
the process in making it playing this
character
all of the people the world that i was
entering
even the world that these movies inhabit
not just in terms of story and place and
people and so on but also just the part
of the movie business that these movies
inhabit is entirely new to me and uh
it was
just
unimaginable unimaginably exciting i
mean just unimaginably exciting
what has your experience been like
coming into the group and
being another
the new gal
it's been awesome i was first really
intimidated by all of the people i was
going to potentially work with
and then everyone was incredibly
welcoming and it's just been
so much fun and it's it's fun to bring a
new element to the game i don't know how
you top ultron
bad guy wise you know the the great
thing about marvel is they've always got
the next thing up their sleeve
so uh
well you know we've got thanos
[Applause]
where's my rose
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we love you guys so much we're so
excited thanks for coming we're going to
keep trying to do our best for you
ladies and gentlemen the avengers age of
ultron out in may of 2015. please
continue to stay on your feet a huge
round of applause for the entire cast
the beige of ultron and for josh